la première ministre depuis le 24 juin
2022 l'avortement n'est plus un droit
fédéral aux États-Unis l'atteinte à ce
droit fondamental fragile sur le plan
juridique dans l'une des plus grandes
démocraties du monde confirme la
réversibilité des droits des femmes et
l'impérieuse nécessité de garantir
constitutionnellement le droit à l'IVG
face aux assauts de forces
réactionnaires c'est pourquoi dès le 30
juin 2022 la majorité présidentielle
déposa une proposition constitutionnel
visant à garantir le droit à d'IVG et
que par la suite députés puis sénateurs
dans une démarche transpartisane ont
adopté tour à tour deux textes
constitutionnels allant dans ce sens
aujourd'hui avec la mobilisation de
nombreux parlementaires et des
associations féministes le président de
la République a annoncé déposer au
Conseil d'État un projet de loi
constitutionnel il ouvre ainsi la voix à
un processus de réforme
constitutionnelle inédit dans le monde
afin de garantir pleinement la liberté
des femmes à pouvoir recourir à l'IVG en
France la vulnérabilité des droits des
femmes est une réalité implacable
l'intérêt de la constitutionnalisation
de ce droit est donc double à la fois
lui conférer une plus grande sécurité
juridique et le rendre irréversible pour
les générations futures et d'autre part
manifester avec force l'attachement de
la France à ce droit fondamental des
femmes à travers cette décision
pionnière le président de la République
rappelle combien ce droit loin d'être
seulement un sujet de femme est au cœur
de notre vie démocratique ici en France
pays des Lumières pays des droits de
l'homme et assurément des droits des
femmes madame la Première ministre quand
le droit à l'IVG sera-t-il pérénisé en
France et inscrit dans notre
Constitution merci beaucoup ma cher
collègue la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Marie-Pierre ixin il y a une
chose que toutes les femmes ne savent
que trop bien leurs droits sont fragiles
et Simone de beauauvoir disait vrai en
affirmant qu'il serait toujours les
premiers remis en question au cœur de
ces droits il y a celui de disposer de
son corps il y a la garantie de pouvoir
librement recourir à l'interruption
volontaire de
grossesse ce droit est le fruit d'une
lutte du Manifeste des TR 343 du procès
de bobini ce droit est le fruit du
courage celui de Simon Veil à la tribune
de cette
assemblée si ce droit est aujourd'hui
défendu sur la quasi-ttalité des bancs
de cet hémicycle nous avons un devoir de
vigilance vous l'avez rappelé la
décision de la Cour suprême des
États-Unis l'année dernière rappeler que
le droit à l'avortement pouvait être
menacé même dans une grande démocratie
et jusque sur notre continent plusieurs
partis d'extrême droite veulent remettre
en cause cette liberté fondamentale pour
les
femmes ce devoir de vigilance vous le
partagez c'est le sens de la proposition
de loi constitutionnelle adopté à une
très large majorité sur ses bans et voté
ensuite par le Sénat ce devoir de
vigilance nous le partageons 8 mars
dernier en rendant l'hommage de la
Nation à Giselle Alimi le président de
la République s'est engagé à inscrire le
droit à l'IVG dans le marbre de la
Constitution et dimanche dernier après
concertation avec les groupes
parlementaires le président de la
République a annoncé qu'un projet de loi
constitutionnel serait transmis dès
cette semaine au Conseil d'État et
présenté au Conseil des ministres avant
la fin de l'année ce texte permettra de
consacrer plus encore la liberté des
femmes à à recourir à l'IVG en
l'inscrivant dans la Constitution
mesdames et messieurs les députés
certains affirment qu'il n'y a pas
urgence pour le droit des femmes je
crois au contraire qu'il y a toujours
urgence à se battre toujours urgence à
veiller aux libertés des femmes c'est ma
conviction c'est la conviction de mon
gouvernement et c'est la et c'est la
vôtre et c'est une conviction qui
rassemble largement sur ces bancs c'est
pourquoi pour toutes les femmes avec le
président de la République nous
souhaitons que ce ce droit soit inscrit
dans la Constitution en 2024 je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première
ministre